how we doing christina um i was
wondering how can i help my aggressive
preschooler
oh man so tell me what you mean by
aggressive
well um he often hits
or destroys things mostly
um hitting other people and it's
become more and more of an issue and i'm
sure a lot of it has to do with
the stress of this year because this
year has been a wreck for everyone
yeah compounded by covid one of the
things
i instantly think of when i hear about
kids
and behavior especially little kids but
really all kids
is behavior is a language right behavior
is just a signal
so what is this little kid trying to say
in whatever environment they are in
so walk me back to the beginning of this
year for you
what's it been like for you you say it's
been awful and bananas what does that
actually mean
well um for the last
well i was pregnant at the beginning of
the year so that was one thing so
i've had a baby since then and
during the time that the pandemic
started
there was a tenant who lived downstairs
who was an exchange student
and he wasn't able to go home when he
was originally planning to
and he thought that my kids were just
too loud and inconsiderate
and he would pound on the floor um
so like from below and it would scare us
and like we've we had some frightening
episodes that eventually led to panic
attacks
and we stayed at my parents house for a
time
until things settled down so you're
you're answering your own question right
hartley's but like he's also been
aggressive even since he was a little
baby
because as a baby he would even hurt
himself where like we had to hold him
down so he wouldn't like scratch his
face and pull his hair out
yeah and some of that for sometimes
you start trying to look for the cause
of a behavior or the reality of a
behavior
and you start grabbing data points from
all over the place
most of the time a kid who's an infant
who scratches himself or pulls her hair
is just simply trying to figure out
their own body
that would be unrelated to aggression or
some sort of inborn anger issue now of
course there could be some some
psychological issues but
what you've just laid out to me is a
lot of stresses this kid's everything
this
this young kid knows how old is he four
three and a half three and a half okay
everything in this three and a half year
old's life has changed
a hundred percent he had mom's attention
now he's got to share it
um he had a safe house now he's got
somebody banging on the floors making
him be quiet
he had a mom who had a life that was
somewhat routine
and now you're living at somebody else's
house everything is dumped over
where's dad in this picture he's been
around he's been
working or doing school from home
throughout the year
and what what type of dad is he is he
connected dad or plugged in dad or a
everybody shut up i'm trying to do
school dad what kind of dad is he
um most of the time like he's really
good at
spending time with the family when he
doesn't have to work on school
stuff but it's been like more and more
stressful as the year has come
gone on so like he's been a little bit
more
tense as well right and so
children especially young children but
almost all kids really
they absorb that tension
and they process it as though it's their
fault
and then they spend all of their life
trying to mitigate it
and for a kid that tension is a broken
relationship with its k
with their caregivers which is you and
your husband a three and a half year old
cannot process
a new baby has just moved in a three and
a half year old cannot process
stressed out parents a three and a half
year old especially can't process
mom and dad are present they're in the
house
physically but they are not emotionally
or mentally present because they're
having to work from home or do school
from home
and so everything in your kids life has
gone up in smoke if you will so
here's a couple so backing out to my
original question
what's your kid trying to say your kid
is trying to tell you that they're not
safe
that they are disconnected that there
are no
boundaries things are free-flowing and i
don't know where i'm going to live i
don't know who's going to be banging on
our floors etc
so here's here's a couple of things i
can give you to
help you walk through it number one kids
are desperate
desperate for sleep and nutrition
they are desperate for connection and
they are desperate for boundaries
okay so sleep and and
nutrition tired exhausted over
sugared kids kids with allergies or
discomfort from food
that just feel uncomfortable all the
time kids who just
are plugged into electronics all the
time and so they don't when they are
asleep they're not actually going into
their full
rem cycle sleep um kids who are not
running around
outside and are locked into an apartment
and i know that's
so hard during pandemic depending on
what what city you live in
and what jurisdiction you live in
because some are just shut down you
can't leave your apartment at all ever
and that's wreaking havoc on little kids
the second thing is they're desperate
for connection
and when i mean connection i mean the
whole world
stops you get down an eye level you look
kids in the eye you touch them
a lot and you've probably heard me say
that over and over whether it's touching
their their hands or their feet or their
face
um having a nighttime ritual that
includes lots and lots of
safe heavy touch on a child
whether that's playing getting down on
their level and playing laying on your
stomach and playing legos or blocks with
a three and a half year old that's
reading
age-appropriate books right
if there's no abuse and there's no hurt
then connection is
a great gift if there is abuse if there
is fear in a kid then that
that connection can be traumatic too so
that's a whole other situation i don't
hear that here
and then the next the last thing here is
boundaries
if a three and a half year old feels
like they are running your house
and what i mean by that is if they can
scream and not eat something
if they can kick and scream and you'll
just shove a tv in front of them or an
ipad in front of them
then they are in essence running the
house and
that destroys a kid they aren't designed
to carry that sort of weight
and they are desperate for mom and dad
to put up boundaries
put up um barriers that they will lean
and press to make sure they'll hold
but they're desperate for them because
then it makes them feel safe it's like
swaddling i remember the first time i
swaddled my son i thought i was
i was going to kill him like it was the
worst nightmare for me that someone
would tie my arms in like that
until a doctor buddy of mine explained
no that's when they feel safe they don't
feel safe with these wild appendages
flying around scratching them and
pulling their hair out because they
don't know how they work
they feel safe when they're bound up and
so when you look back
over the course of this year i want you
to be graceful to yourself as a mom
because it's been chaos
i want you to be graceful to yourself as
a brand new mom because you've got a um
what like a nine month old in your house
and now a three and a half year old
but i want you to do some things that
are going to draw some boundaries here's
some boundaries
you cannot hit in this home you cannot
scream in this home
that's not it's not a tool that works
for you
i am going to intentionally put down um
the little one or give the little one to
dad and i'm going to spend some very
direct connective time with you
on a regular basis at a regular time if
possible
and that way we can build in time
boundaries with their kids we can build
in
attention connection boundaries with our
kid i'm gonna make
super sure that the moment he wakes up
i'm gonna give him skin to skin contact
direct skin to skin contact i'm gonna
make sure that before lunch
after nap and right before bed there's
some direct skin to skin contact
and i also i haven't experienced this
but i've just heard over and over for
moms when you are in this season when
you're still nursing you still got a
young one at home
your body doesn't feel like yours and
the last thing you want to do is touch
another kid last thing you want to do is
touch your spouse just don't touch
anybody
but i'll tell you those investments in
touch those investments in eye contact
will pay off
in a decrease screaming a decrease
biting
and kicking and a decreased
language of will somebody please
freaking look at me
will somebody please acknowledge me and
that's all your three and a half year
old is doing with his little languages
he has
if things like attention if things like
limited screen time if things like
bedtime routines where you're getting a
lot of sleep
a lot of sleep for a young kid like that
probably 10 to 12 hours for a young kid
like that
a lot of nutrition no sugar
very limited stuff out of a box give a
kid as healthy as
food as y'all can afford if those things
don't work
then i'm going to recommend you go see a
psychologist but i want you to spend 30
days
double down on the connection double
down on boundaries time boundaries
double down on space double down on
consistency
and here's the hard thing for moms and
dads listening to this
this means that you all are going to
have to be highly highly intentional
you have to be highly intentional about
when you wake up and how much sleep you
get
about meal plep and meal meal prep and
meal planning
you're going to be intentional about
budgets you're going to be intentional
about who does just shopping you have to
be intentional all those things that
couples just let roll especially when
you got a newborn in the house
you're gonna have to be overly
intentional about it
and then you're gonna have to really
communicate with your husband sounds
like he's an awesome guy something he's
a great dude who's plugged in and trying
to help the best he can while
doing two or three other things
here's the other thing this is a season
and it will pass this season
is hard this season sucks this scene is
weighing season to win everybody and if
you're in an apartment
with an angry tenant surrounding you
that does not understand the beauty of
little kids
and who's a jerk who's banging on the
ceiling like an idiot
and if you've got two little babies in
that house it's just hard
it just is and so um try those things
with your little one call me back if
they don't work call me back if they do
work that would be great to know